Ingerir glúten até duas vezes por semana
é tão prejudicial assim para alguém
saudável? Olá pessoal, que bom estar
aqui com vocês novamente. Hoje vamos
bater um papo sobre uma pergunta que
chega muito no meu consultório e que
também recebo bastante nas redes
sociais. Doutor, se eu comer glúten só
duas vezes por semana, será que faz mal
assim? Essa é uma daquelas perguntas que
parecem simples, mas que na verdade
abrem uma caixa de Pandora super
interessante. Eu vou contar para vocês o
que que a ciência mais recente está
mostrando sobre isso. E posso adiantar
que as descobertas são bem
surpreendentes. Primeiro, deixa eu
contextualizar uma coisa bem importante
aqui. Quando falamos de glúten, não
estamos falando apenas daquelas pessoas
que têm a chamada doença ceríaca, OK?
Estudos recentes publicados em revistas
como a Nature Communications e no BMJ
tem mostrado que o glúten pode afetar
pessoas aparentemente saudáveis. Também
é como se fosse aquela história do
iceberg. A parte que a gente vê na
superfície é só uma pequena porção do
que realmente está acontecendo. Agora
vamos ao que interessa. Pesquisadores
dinamarqueses fizeram um estudo super
interessante, super bacana, com 60
adultos saudáveis, sem nenhum problema
conhecido com glúten. Veja bem, não
tinham problema nenhum com glúten. Eles
compararam uma dieta com baixo glúten,
seca de 2 g por dia, com uma dieta rica
em glúten 18 g de áos. E olha só o que
eles descobriram mesmo. Pessoas
saudáveis tiveram mudanças no microbioma
intestinal, redução no inchaço quando
diminuiram o glúten. Mas aqui que fica
interessante, o Dr. Alécio Fazano, um
dos maiores pesquisadores mundiais nessa
área, descobriu algo revolucionário. Ele
identificou uma proteína chamada
zonulina, que é como se fosse a chave
que controla a permeabilidade do nosso
intestino. E adivinha só? Lutem tem a
capacidade de ativar essa zonulina em
qualquer pessoa, não só em quem tem
doença celíaca. É como se nosso destino
tivesse uma barreira bem organizada,
tipo aquele segurança de festa VIP.
Quando tudo está funcionando direitinho,
eles só deixam passar quem deveria
passar. Mas quando o glúten aparece, ele
meio que confunde o sistema e faz com
que essa barreira fique mais relaxada,
permitindo que substâncias que não
deveriam passar consigam atravessar. O
que me impressiona é que estudos
recentes mostraram que isso acontece em
todo o mundo, mas a intensidade, a
duração são diferentes. Em pessoas
saudáveis, essa abertura da barreira
intestinal é mais discreta e temporária.
Já em pessoas com sensibilidade ao
glúten ou doença celícol.
Agora, voltando à pergunta original,
duas vezes por semana faz mal? Bom, aqui
que a coisa fica interessante. Um estudo
brasileiro que foi publicado em 2023
mostrou que o consumo esporádico de
glúten
aqueles sintomas gritantes que vemos na
doença celíca, mas pode sim gerar uma
inflamação de baixo grau que vai se
acumulando com o tempo. É como se fosse
aquela goteirinha chata no teto de casa.
Uma gotinha aqui, outra ali. Parece que
não é nada demais.
Mas depois de um tempo você olha e tem
uma mancha no teto, o pior começou a
apodrecer a madeira. O glúten esporádico
pode funcionar assim, criando uma
inflamação silenciosa que ao longo dos
anos pode sim contribuir para problemas
que a gente nem imagina que estão
relacionados. Estudos recentes também
mostraram algo fascinante sobre a nossa
genética. Existe uma proteína chamada
aptoglobina.
E dependendo do tipo que você redul seus
pais, sua reação ao glúten bem
diferente. Cerca de 80% da população tem
um tipo que reage mais facilmente ao
glúten, enquanto os outros 20% são mais
resistentes. É meio que uma loteria
genética. Mas pera aí, antes de vocês
saírem daqui achando que o Gruto é o
vilão da história, deixa eu trazer outro
lado da moeda. Pesquisas publicadas no
BMJ acompanharam mais de 60.000 pessoas
por décadas e descobriram que evitar o
glút
desnecessariamente pode ter sim algumas
desvantagens. Vou explicar. Calma lá.
Muitos produtos sem glúten mais
processados, tem mais açúcar, menos
fibras que as versões com glúten. Eu
falo isso direto com meus pacientes. É
aquela velha história que eu sempre falo
aqui. Não existe bala de prata na saúde,
pessoal. Cada caso é um caso e o que
funciona para uma pessoa pode não
funcionar para outra. Na minha prática
clínica, com mais de 25 anos de
experiência, quase 30, o que eu tenho
observado é que uma abordagem mais
integrativa funciona melhor. Então, ao
invés de focar apenas no tirar o glúten
ou pode comer à vontade, eu prefiro
olhar o quadro como um todo. Como é que
está a saúde intestinal da pessoa, qual
que é o nível de estresse, como é que
anda o sono, que outros alimentos estão
sendo consumidos. Uma coisa interessante
que estudos recentes mostraram
é que a qualidade do glúten também
importa muito. Olha só, qualidade do
glúten. O trigo moderno, que passou por
várias modificações ao longo das
décadas, tem concentrações de glúten
muito maiores que os grãos antigos. É
como comparar uma cervejinha artesanal
com aquela aguada do supermercado.
Tecnicamente são a mesma coisa, né? são
cerveja, mas na prática são bem
diferentes. Então, respondendo
diretamente a pergunta duas vezes por
semana, pode sim fazer diferença
dependendo da pessoa, especialmente se
você já tem alguma tendência a problemas
inflamatórios intestinais ou autoimunes.
Nesse caso, não recomendo. Não é
necessariamente uma sentença de morte
tomar duas vezes por semana, mas também
não é algo que devemos ignorar
completamente. O que eu recomendo para
os meus pacientes é fazer o teste
prático. Tenta ficar um mês
completamente sem utilizar o glúten e
ver como é que o seu organismo responde.
Depois reintroduz gradualmente observa
se aparece sintomas como inchaço, de
cabeça, mudança de humor ou digestão
alterada. Seu próprio corpo vai te dar
as respostas mais precisas que qualquer
exame. E lembra, gente, não é só sobre o
glúten em si, é sobre criar um estilo de
vida que permita que o nosso corpo
funcione da melhor forma possível. às
vezes duas vezes por semana pode ser
perfeitamente tolerável para uma pessoa
com boa saúde intestinal, exercitando-se
regularmente e com baixo estresse. Para
outra pessoa, com o intestino já zoado,
todo comprometido e outros fatores de
risco, pode ser o suficiente para manter
um estado inflamatório crônico. Então, a
boa notícia é que o nosso corpo é
incrível em se regenerar quando damos as
condições corretas e adequadas. Então,
estudos mostram que a barreira
intestinal pode se recuperar
relativamente rápido quando removemos os
fatores irritantes e fornecemos
nutrientes adequados para ela. Por isso,
minha dica final é: discute o seu corpo,
teste na prática e, se possível, busque
orientação de um profissional que
entenda do que tá fazendo dessa
abordagem mais funcional, integrativa,
para te ajudar a interpretar os sinais
que o seu organismo está dando. E você
já experimentou ficar sem glúte por um
tempo, por 30 dias? Vale a pena. Você
vai notar alguma diferença. Conta aí nos
comentários a sua experiência se você já
fez. E se esse vídeo foi útil para você,
não esquece deixar o seu like, se
inscrever no canal para mais conteúdos
como esse. Até a próxima, pessoal.